HERE, AND THEY'RE UNDER
NOT TO SAY EXACTLY WFOR.
ENIS
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN MATT  NEN
OSIMN A L
INVESTIGATIO
WHAT DO YOU KNOWS
>> WELL,HE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IIS
ERIN, IS THE QE
WITNS.W THAT THE S HAVE PLEAD
TO SIMILAR A GAETZ
IS UNDER INVESTIGATIONORWE KNOWN
THE BIGGEST ISSUR
PRUTD S IS
VERY DIFFICULT TO PRESENT FINAL
CONGRESSWOMAN ZO LOFGREN,  JANU.
SOMAN, I WANT TO GET
TESTIFYINNALDME.IRST, TERPRETAW
BE GLL INOIS WHAVEWSTTEE HAS N
INFORMATION ABOU.
BUT, CLEARLYE EX-PREMPD TO OVERL
JUDGE IN THE
THAT IT  LIKELY TH MR. TRUVIOL
RNIVILEGE ISF THCONSULTAONS
IN FURTHERANCE O
THEASTMASEBUT I T ON
>> CLEVEN, IUNDSHE
RASKIN JUSSAE SELECTE O REVE LYX
UARYth
WHICH IS SIGNIFICANT.
RASKD HE'S SAW
WHERLE MEETING WITH HE EVENUARY
WHICH COULD BE
SIT OF INVESGATIVE
BEING DONE ON THATNT.AT ELSS?>>T
WHENTOE INE TOOK THE
FIFTH AMENDMENT RE.WEONS THAT T
N TW S TWE  STEVE BANNON.
E CTSTDE
CONNECTION THESE
INT OU
AND YOU'RE YOUO KNOW
THOSE MEETINGS, AND I'
AFR, DIDN'T,
BUT AFTER THOSE  I DIDN'SATENO
WORD.WE
COUNWEEN TRUMP AND
THOUGH YOU DON WAS HE COMMUNICA.
HE RULES
INTO THE COMMITTEE TO GOTHE DET.
W THAT A THE
GR WD G PART IN OSITH IST AT EXO
E Y 6t
AIRBNB.I SPOKE OTHER DAYO THE OF
HE SAW AE SURGOFKI, LED HIM
TO BELIEVERELDMORE
CE A
>> WE CANCELEDRY RESERVA D.CE ,H
>> WHAT DID THE MAGOVERNORS DO
NDM TO
YOU FORNG OUT AND THEY REALLY
APPRECIATED THE PARTNERSHIP.
AND WE
HELP?
WE WANT TOON SIDE,
NOT THE WRON CONCERNED
WITH PUBLIC SAFETYE DIDN'T
JANUARY 6th-LIKERE THEREAN AL.
>> WELE WEREG
CLOSELY WH POSSIBLE TOOR S.
ALWAYS A POTENTIAL ON TION DAY
SUOUALD
STRONGE.IONAL GUD,OFRA
OF PE 20th WAS ABLE TO
OCCUR.
AND THK D IT DID.
SO, ALL OF